you know it's funny even after seeing
dwayne johnson play the tooth fairy
i never really expected him to play in
evangelizing jesus-loving christian i
really did not see that one coming
pain and gain is directed by the one and
only Michael Bay and it stars Mark
Wahlberg Dwayne Johnson Anthony Mackie
and Tony Shalhoub this movie is about
three bodybuilders and they are sick of
their life they want more money they
want more out of life but they just
can't seem to get it because they keep
screwing up and everything they try to
do so the three of these guys come
together and they cook up this plot to
rob one of the people who goes to the
gym that they go to now this guy is very
rich and he's a jerk so they think he's
the perfect candidate to take all his
money but they have to force him to sign
away all of his money and then the movie
progresses on this trip in which all of
them try to live these lives that they
always wanted now I was excited about
this movie because they're you know I'm
not like a hater of Michael Bay he's
made some really crappy movies in the
past
I actually think pearl harbors a little
offensive to be honest like it turned
like a really tragic event into like
this big popcorn movie Armageddon is
just cheesy cheesy 90s fun but I grew up
with it on VHS tape so it doesn't really
bother me in that way he's made some fun
movies before I actually legitimately
like the rock the first Transformers
movies a lot of fun the second one was
pretty bad and then third one was better
but you know it's just he has a style
and when you see his movies you know
okay this is a Michael Bay movie for
sure it's gonna have a lot of
oversaturated colors lots and lots of
slow motion lots and lots of tilted
camera angles as people stand on a big
beach or a long highway of some kind as
the tilted camera angle zooms in on them
you're gonna have a lot of that in a
Michael Bay movie you're gonna have a
lot of strippers that a lot of fake
women who look like Barbie dolls and
porn stars and you're gonna have quite a
bit of pyrotechnics on display now pain
and gain has a much smaller budget than
his previous films so there aren't as
much pyrotechnics in this movie but they
are definitely there and the other thing
that you're probably going to get in a
Michael Bay movie is at least one
character who's just like the biggest
jerk who runs his mouth constantly this
movie is filled with these characters
now I did some research on this movie
after I saw it because they do say that
it is a true story
in fact they really make it clear this
is a true story and there are
in the movie that I'm sure are
completely just exaggerated for
entertainment purposes but a lot of the
elements that are shown in this movie
the ones that you think are just so
horrible this could never happen it
actually did happen and so before I tell
you how I feel about this movie let me
just explain that this movie depicts a
lot of murderous tragic events done by
criminals who appeared to be very
bloodthirsty because they wanted to
become very rich and the movie depicts
these events in a very comedic sense a
very over-the-top in-your-face let's
laugh about this sense and I did a
little research and some of the victims
of the families of the people who were
actually murdered by these guys are a
little offended by that and you know
what I honestly would be too so I
there's an aspect of this film that is a
little offensive and you know it's a
Michael Bay movie so what are you gonna
expect but for the most part I was let
down by pain and gain because it really
just felt like that cliched Michael Bay
movie that we get so often it's like 2
hours and 10 minutes long like a good 20
minutes could have been cut out of this
movie lots and lots of forced humor lots
and lots of slow-motion walking away
from explosions with sunglasses on this
movie is trying so hard to be an assault
on your senses like certain elements of
the movie are trying so hard to be funny
but it's hard to even laugh because it's
just constant constant stuff screamed at
you and like every character in this
movie except for Dwayne Johnson is just
a giant jerk I mean you can't really
sympathize with these guys but the film
at times is trying to make you do that
these guys were serious criminals and
they kind of want you to sympathize with
them and I just I can't bring myself to
do that when I know that these events
actually happened there are good things
about the movie though I do admire the
main three actors Mark Wahlberg Dwayne
Johnson and Anthony Mackie these are
good actors and Mark Wahlberg is good as
his character but his character is so
just obnoxious that it's a little bit
hard to like that character or to really
even enjoy watching that character you
see the thing is the film seems like
it's trying so hard to make you like
them but you just you don't and that's
why it's really hard to to really latch
on to this movie sometimes is because I
feel like it's conflicted with itself
since these events actually happened
it's kind of depicting some pretty
terrible events but then the film is
also trying to be so funny and likeable
that I feel like it's just I can
really do that I can't enjoy watching
that because it happened Dwayne
Johnson's character is the one you're
supposed to really sympathize with he
loves Jesus praise Jesus all the time he
says that and he's really under the idea
of bettering yourself and not being
involved with violence and because of
that because of him playing that
character it was pretty entertaining to
watch and I did like his character
Anthony Mackie seemed like that typical
Michael Bay fodder character where you
just are in a movie to just foul up a
whole bunch of really quick lines that
are supposed to be really funny and
clever but it doesn't really work that
way and of course there is the Megan Fox
look-alike chick throughout the
beginning of this movie that then
transfers into another stripper Michael
Bay chick you literally can't act like
worth a dime pain and gain for me isn't
a movie that you're going to sit down
and necessarily be bored with I mean
Michael Bay movies are rarely ever
boring it's just that they always
overstay their welcome I wish that he
would make a film that was more simple I
just don't really think that's in him
you can make whatever he wants to make
it's his life it's his career but I'm
just I'm I'm getting sick of the whole
Michael Bay explosion in your face slow
motion over processed color stripper
girls thing in every single movie it's
just not entertaining to me anymore I'm
gonna give pain and gain a c-minus so if
you guys see the movie this weekend let
me know what you thought below I hope
you enjoyed the film if you just want to
go have a good time but if you feel the
same way as I do let me know if you feel
differently that's fine too I don't care
it's perfectly fine and as always guys
thanks for watching and if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
mine eyes
[Music]